entre 2500 et 3000 porcs sont abattus
chaque semaine dans ses locaux situés à
houdan l'abattoir guillard ans est le
dernier établissement de ce type en
ile-de-france depuis 2013 les normes
européennes du bien-être animal ont été
renforcées vincent hareng directeur de
l'abattoir yvelinois s'assure du respect
de ces règles vous mettons les ports par
deux dans des ascenseurs et des cendres
dans une concentration à 90 % de co2 qui
les endort immédiatement une fois que
donc les cochons dorment complètement
ils sont saignés donc nous on récupère
le sens et après sa part sur la chaîne
d'abattage une machine validé par la
direction départementale de la
protection des populations et par une
association de protection animale mais
les vidéos publiées sur internet en
octobre 2015 par l'association l214 ont
incité l'abattoir à prendre de nouvelles
mesures
depuis les premières vidéos donc nous
avons bien regardé tout ce qui aurait pu
ne pas aller donc maintenant notre taux
de co2 était avant affiché sur une
petite affiche maintenant c'est une
grosse lumière verte ou rouge
si sévère on peut tuer si c'est rouge on
arrête tout parce que l'animal risque de
ne pas être assez endormie selon vincent
hareng les abattoirs n'ont aucun
avantage maltraité un animal le stress
et la souffrance altère la qualité de la
viande et entraîne donc des pertes
financières
l'établissement de 90 salariés fait
l'objet d'un contrôle annuel complet en
plus d'un contrôle quotidien de la ddpp
une équipe de 5 personnes en permanence
qui j'allais dire ça se fait
régulièrement abattoirs deux axes
principaux la protection animale
vérifiez donc si les animaux qui
arrivent à l'abattoir donc des ports
c'était un match ouvert uniquement de
porcs ne sont pas blessés ne sont pas
malades et bien entendu la sécurité
sanitaire des aliments
en cas de non respect des lois en
vigueur les établissements sont
sanctionnés des peines pouvant aller
jusqu'au licenciement du salarié
concerné ou la fermeture de l'abattoir
après la nouvelle publication d'une
vidéo de l214 fin mars
stéphane le foll le ministre de
l'agriculture a ordonné aux préfets de
procéder à des inspections dans
l'ensemble des abattoirs du pays
elles doivent être réalisés avant la fin
du mois d'avril